♪ ♪
>> Tucker: FOR TWO YEARS THEY
TOLD THAT ROBERT MUELLER WAS A
MORAL HERO.
QUESTIONING HIM WAS A BETRAYAL
OF THIS COUNTRY.
HIRING HIM WOULD BE TREASON.
THE ONLY REAL QUESTION BUT
ROBERT MUELLER, OR TWO BUT HIS
STATUE?
IT SHOULD BE AT LEAST AS BIG AS
LINCOLN.
ON SUNDAY HE DASHED THEIR
DREAMS.
AFTER CONDUCTING THE MOST
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION IN
AMERICAN HISTORY HE CONCLUDED
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION BETWEEN
THE BRUSHES TO MIKE RUSSIANS.
THE STOCK MARKET CRASH,
LITERALLY.
RATINGS ON CNN AND MSNBC OMITTED
IMMEDIATELY IN SOME CASES MORE
THAN 50%.
THEY PROMISED THEIR AUDIENCE A
CONSPIRACY AND ONE THAT
EVAPORATED SO TO THEIR VIEWERS.
DEMOCRATIC OFFICEHOLDERS FACED A
SIMILAR PROBLEM.
WHAT YOU SAY TO THE MOB ON
TWITTER THAT BELIEVES THAT TRUMP
SPEAKS RUSSIAN?
TOUGH QUESTION.
WE DECIDED TO SAY NOTHING,
NOTHING HAS CHANGED.
WATCH SENATOR CORY BOOKER, THIS
CONTINUES, ONLY NOW THE NEWLY
INSULTED ATTORNEY GENERAL AS
PART OF THE CONSPIRACY TOO.
>> BOB MUELLER DID NOT FIND A
CHARGEABLE COLLUSION CONSPIRACY.
HERE'S HOW YOU DESCRIBED IT AS
RECENTLY AS 2017.
>> OUT THERE CONTINUES TO BE
SMOKE THAT MIGHT RESULT IN AN
ACTUAL FIRE.
WE'RE COLLUSION GOING ON BETWEEN
US AND THE SOVIET UNION.
>> Tucker: REAL COLLUSION.
>> DO YOU HAVE TO ADVISE THAT IS
A NONDISCHARGEABLE?
>> AND ATTORNEY GENERAL IN MY
OPINION IS SUSPECT FILTERING A
REPORT THAT I HAVE NOT SEEN.
I'M NOT WILLING TO CONCLUDE
ANYTHING ELSE.
>> Tucker: CONGRESSMAN ERIC
SWELLABLE IS LESS CREATIVE THAN
THAT.
HE DOESN'T HAVE A THEORY ABOUT
THAT OR ANYTHING.
THEY WORKED FOR HIM.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
ANY OF YOUR EVIDENCE OR FACTS.
HE LIKES THE WORLD AS IT WAS
LAST WEEK.
DON'T BOTHER ARGUING WITH HIM.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT THEN YOU
CAN SUE.
>> I STAND BY WHAT I SAID ABOUT
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT
YOU CAN SUE ME AND I WOULD WIN."
>> Tucker: JUST SUE ME.
IN CNN THERE WAS NEAR PANIC
ABOUT THE NEWS, LET'S SAY YOU
SPENT DECADES CLAIMING TO BE THE
MOST TRUSTED NAME AND NEWS AND
THEN IT TURNED OUT YOU ARE WAY
LESS RELIABLE THAN ALEX JONES BY
THE WAY YOU FORCED OFF THE AIR
ALERTLY ON THE GROUNDS THAT HE
WAS TOO INACCURATE TO BE HEARD
BY THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
YOU WOULD BE WORRIED ALL THE
SUN.
YOU WOULD WANT TO APOLOGIZE
BECAUSE THAT IS THE SAME AS
ACKNOWLEDGING YOUR FRAUD SO YOU
KEEP LYING.
WATCH THE GOVERNOR'S BROTHER DO
JUST THAT.
>> THIS NETWORK HAVE TORTURED
THIS MAN FOR TWO YEARS WITH
COLLUSION AND NOBODY IS
APOLOGIZING!
BEFORE WE TALK ABOUT THAT,
APOLOGIZE TO THE OVERREACTION OF
COLLUSION.
>> NOT A CHANCE.
>> APOLOGIZED!
>> NEVER.
I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING WRONG.
THESE QUESTIONS ARE REAL.
THEY NEED TO BE REGARDED AS
SUCH.
>> Tucker: APOLOGIZE?
APOLOGIZING NEVER EVEN OCCURRED
TO DON LAMON.
HE IS A BUSY MAN.
HE DOESN'T HAVE TIME TO READ THE
ENTIRE SUMMARY OF THE REPORT.
HE HAS PEOPLE FOR THAT.
FROM THE BACK OF HIS MAY BLOCK
HEADING HOME FROM DINNER, A LINE
ON INSTAGRAM WAS ENOUGH.
HE KNOWS WHAT HE KNOWS.
>> HE QUOTES HIM SAYING WHILE
THIS REPORT DOES NOT CONCLUDE
THE PRESIDENT COMMITTED A CRIME
BUT DOES NOT EXONERATE HIM.
IT DOES NOT EXONERATE HIM.
AND IT DOES NOT ALSO EXONERATE
HIM.